[Music]  uh  here are three ways you can be more  inclusive in everyday life  one have an open mind and be willing to  adapt remember  just because someone looks different  than you or maybe uses a wheelchair  doesn't mean that they can't dance or do  the same things that you do  two be kind don't be afraid to ask  someone how their day is going and just  say hello  the best way to make someone feel  included is to show them that you care  three don't be afraid to step out of  your comfort zone look for ways that you  can surround yourself with people who  aren't just like you and you may be  surprised  at who you meet and what you learn  remember inclusion benefits  everyone  you